who honks during a traffic jam someone
cuts you off or starts dancing on your
car sure even the biggest asshat knows
it's not the fault of the guy in front
of you but if I'm in a traffic jam and
someone in front of me gets out and
starts singing and dancing you can bet
your ass I'm laying on my horn like a
road rage Rodney sorry I guess I
momentarily thought road rage rodney was
a thing I apologies sin still stands
though also oh sure traffic jams are an
LA staple these crews are stopped cold
for several minutes which probably means
there's a hideous accident up ahead but
these dancing assholes are completely
ignored dad Oh bonnet more so watching
on every doing okay I know this is a
Hollywood movie with a gigantic
Hollywood boner but this opening number
makes it look like everyone in Los
Angeles is either currently or
prospectively in the entertainment
business it's like other professions
there though right
aren't there actual doctors at the
hospitals for those Crizal actors
waiting for the big break how these
assholes didn't die of heat exhaustion
prior to now is a prequel I'd actually
pay money to see also this is a band
consisting of timpani stand-up bass
flute and marching band bass drum and
yet movie suggests everyone rallies
around this truck to party during the
traffic jam okay it looks like everybody
is having a great time I'm telling you
if you ride your magical appearing outta
nowhere bike or skateboard up on my car
playtime is over yeah but those lanes
down there are moving effortlessly these
assholes on the skybridge apparently
have no clue how to zipper merge hey
movie you're Marilyn Monroe is showing
sebastian is not only able to pull into
that left lane to properly scold mia but
also pulls to a full stop in the middle
of what's now a moving highway to give
her the stink-eye character forgets an
appointment for one of the most
important jobs in their life right now
cliche Mia not only is the only person
in Los Angeles to own a parka with a
fur-lined hood she has it in her car and
can use it to cover the coffee stain at
a moment's notice
okay kudos to the movie for showing us
early on that Mia actually does have
talent we see several bad auditions
later but they aren't about her talent
it's because her heart isn't in it and
she's distracted so when she gets famous
later it's totally believable because of
this seat props also to Emma Stone for
making me emotional in a fake audition
inside a movie also I'm going to go
ahead and take another cent off for Emma
Stone's cry face that's a great cry face
right there other cry faces are gross
and snotty this is a very clean cry face
that I would like to point out this
casting director and the girl that
opened the door in the first place is
addictive terrific acting you know for
starving artists these girls should
resign and looks to be a 31 year old's
vision of how young women in Hollywood
should actually live Mia takes only one
second to wrap up this movie's pg-13
rating so he takes time to introduce us
to Mia's three closest friends who later
will play a key role in helping her
adjust to her new relationship and
issues oh right
we barely hear from them again in the
entire movie most egregious dancing in
the streets since Mick Jagger and David
Bowie man what I going to do with me it
didn't go I'm sure they'd have uber or
something they get right to Mia's car
like she called the all-time didi for
this orphanage of aspiring actresses
movie sets the reddest bathroom since
the shining record that no one thought
would be broken since well the shining
no parking sign and the entirety of Los
Angeles is this simple to understand I
promise you you basically need a degree
in theoretical physics and a graphing
calculator to figure out where and when
you're allowed to park Dan Damien
Chazelle became a master of color and
framing seemingly before he hit puberty
which should be a sin because I'm
jealous but for this shot alone I'm
knocking one on this movie introduces us
to sub sister who later will play a key
role in helping them adjust to his new
relationship and issues oh wait
we barely hear from her again the entire
movie does she like jazz then what are
we going to talk about no pop music the
Middle East why does your date have to
care as much as you do about jazz
because you're living like a hermit
you're driving without insurance hold
the phone there Nancy he's driving
without insurance that's like putting
your whole mouth
right in the dip oh goody now even
Damien Chazelle has an expanded universe
oh wait this shot right here of SEDs
reflection off the tip jar yeah it's
going to get us in for the director
showing off this restaurant audience
sure they're just here for a family meal
and everything but that was excellent
piano Inge in any context inches elicit
some sort of response so this audience
he catched for a chroma topia DOA on
23rd perp laughs and his face off at the
PD Dan Miranda rights this is my
classroom you don't like it the doors to
my left why did she suddenly get sucky
at acting because that guy didn't kiss
her because of the amazing spider-man 2
because of feelings this entire movie
depends on Mia attending some random
party where Sebastian is cosmically also
playing in the hired band this is Los
Angeles coincidences are 10 times less
likely out here due to sheer population
size Iran Iran a fantastic suggestion
yeah I guess Iran kind of describes
their first encounter when you blew her
off
but she seems overly confident this will
get under a skip and yet it does so well
I know I'm honestly surprised he even
remembers her he was so distracted that
night from being fired this is actually
the second movie co-starring Ryan
Gosling and 80s music sarcastic dancing
mio single-handedly provides animated
gifs for the next five years
questing Iran from a serious musician
it's just it's too fun right before that
you were playing take on me so are you
really responsible yourself here you're
in an 80s cover band what did you expect
Supriya I mean if that doesn't help me
awesome King Priya's joke moving I mean
seriously I was laughing so hard I had
to rewind the movie like a whole five
seconds to catch up on what I missed
King hysterical joke get that writer a
raise and a half why is he dressed in a
suit now but earlier was in a t-shirt
and a tease jacket is this the kind of
game where you can play keyboard but
also then change and join the party they
take a suit in the bag to every gig just
in case he meets Emma Stone a movie here
singing in the rain is showing me a
brought her comfortable shoes to the
event tonight but waited until mid song
to actually change them after she'd walk
up a fairly steep hill
[Music]
and this is the moment I felt goosebumps
from my love of old-school Hollywood
music and from that this movie gets yet
another sin off hey it almost won Best
Picture okay it's not like I'm over
praising some straight-to-video bull
that partying after that adorable ass
dance without getting her phone number
is she double clicking that tablet in
the same place with her fingernail on a
clearly blank screen he doesn't know how
to iPad
wait did Mia bring a blue skirt to work
to change into because I'm pretty sure
she was just wearing black pants
I hate dad she says she hates jazz and
then we get this jazzy jazzy montage of
juicing the jazz and well I want these
two to get together as much as the movie
does I cannot condone the forcing of
jazz on those who do not get jazz or
wish to get jazz dying tiny it had its
time indeed it did and while I don't
wish for jazz to die I do think it's a
minority genre that needs to play to its
core audience to stay relevant as
opposed to trying to grow wait so they
were just walking together on the Warner
Brothers lot when Sebastian said what
are you doing right now but then they
went all the way down to this Lighthouse
Cafe which is in Carrozza Beach almost
an hour away and it's a cool shot of
them walking in different directions but
shouldn't either or both of them be
looking for a cab I'm glad she's happy
but where is she going right now and how
is she going to run there in heels the
saint's jurassic world you know Jesus is
everyone required to run down the middle
of the road in the spring town is a
perfectly good sidewalk right there
striking how does she stand directly
between the projector and the screen and
no one even flinches she should be
ducking Milk Duds and ice cubes by this
point this slow bill the hand-holding
scene is adorable but it reminds me too
much of my college girlfriend Molly who
after an awesome date with a similar
slow handhold romance moment proceeded
to say good night to me and then still
somehow suck off some townie named Jared
in the alley before calling it a night
and a memory like that could only mean
sins for a movie like this sorry
[Music]
what are the odds that a film burn would
occur in the projection booth just as
these two are about to kiss for the
first time no seriously give me those
odds because they're astronomical for
sure no that is not a driveway and no
that is not a parking space it just
looks more cinematic than the beat-up
parking lot for the Griffith Observatory
that's just off screen if she's really
floating then I have to question many
things about this movies reality but
this is merely symbolism that it's
beautiful
sadly I have only been paying enough
attention to just barely not know what's
going on yet because I am too famous and
important to still give my work 100% of
my full attention these days dunno so
I'm left to guess that maybe she just
ate too many helium cookies or maybe
everything up till now was someone's
dream and nothing I've seen is real she
i better drop some acid to find out for
sure hey movie your wall-e is showing
sexy dancing sweet jazz sexy dancing
sweet ciao Who am I kidding and a stone
won this battle just as soon as it began
sorry awesome musician Gosling never
said he came here yeah geez MIA exposit
much you know he's in the next king room
right this phone conversation right here
could be blamed for the series of events
that ultimately do in this relationship
[Music]
never before as any movie face better
represented the Sagan now what crowd
jazz is dying because of people like you
replace jazz with film and I hear this
exact sentiment on social media every
day doesn't make it true but still wait
how is this YouTube video playing when
the play icon is still showing and where
the hell is the timestamp this movie
thinks an interview with an experimental
hip-hop jazz group would get eight
hundred ninety nine thousand views movie
knows jack about YouTube damn when this
movie emotionally montages it
emotionally montages heart is the
age-old story of all the young
attractive people attending a jazz
fusion concert then mugging the piano
player during his solo always whips
those kids into a ladder she is even
more surprised about the lack of jazz in
this music than said was during his
audition how many attendees can you
really hope to get for your one-woman
show when you're chief marketing
strategy is a last-minute CC email also
Mia spans all her Hollywood contacts and
doesn't even bother using a blind CC Mia
just know do you like the music you're
playing I don't I don't know what what
it matters let's put this in perspective
here seems like Sebastian's had a pretty
gradual transition from traditionalist
to celebrity but in movie time it's only
been a few months between summer and
fall like three months max this guy was
such a purist he resorted to petty
vandalism of the Samba tapa place like
90 days ago but now he's cool with
wearing a piano tie on stage why aren't
we celebrating why are you turning your
club's Jesus Christ doesn't anyone in
this movie know how to wait and you just
like me when I was on my ass because it
made you feel better by yourself over
the line dude way over the line
end of the record cliche followed
immediately by food burnt in the oven
cliche - rocky relationship metaphor
cliches in five seconds their
relationship must be truly - it was even
trying to make here a giant pot pie
burlap wrapped something hobos do stuff
with newspaper clippings I mean Jesus
this is an abomination even if it isn't
overcooked when your one-woman play is
one night only you are maybe to conserve
the marketing budget and not paper the
town on the way you would if you had a
month-long engagement or you know go
digital with your marketing yell why
would they even turn on the house lights
for a curtain call you keep the stage
lights up so the audience would clearly
see the actor but in this case movie
really wants to put the knife on how
cringy this is also the single biggest
mystery of this movie is how an unknown
one of the actress staged her own
one-woman show for one night only and
actually had people show up seriously
try putting on your own one-person show
in LA is a nobody and see what happens
it'll be the polar opposite of the magic
this girl encounters that's for sure and
worse than that she's actually gonna get
famous after this one of the nine people
who saw this show was so moved as to get
me on an audition for a major movie role
just think being true to result and
playing to an audience of nine paid off
for so obviously you should similarly
ditch wisdom and pursue your foolish
dreams including a job if YouTube trolls
actually left the house and went to
place in Brant the casting director she
was at your play she was one of the nine
people who showed up because Hollywood
casting directors give the finger to
math and ODS when going out to scout
local talent and attend mostly one woman
or one man shows that have little to no
word about yeah she stops in here but
blush Sebastien drove from mother to Los
Angeles to Boulder City but gave me a
six seconds after pulling up to the
house in the morning he's trusting this
drive back to LA for the most important
audition of her life - this car Sky's
part of a successful jazz hip-hop fusion
band
somehow and they were on tour for so
long it broke these two up basically and
my point is he should have a way more
reliable car than this by now and a
still owns this scene the emotion the
acting the singing the vulnerability
this scene might have won the movie all
the tasker's once in renew when you find
out they said the next couple days this
question must have had Sebastian doubled
over in suspense considering he waited
until they traveled all the way the
Observatory to ask it after the audition
yeah you're about 20 minutes from the
end of the film and don't have time
enough for this question to be asked
this late also I'm pretty sure you
clearly broke up so I'm not sure why
you're asking for clarification like we
broke up then you helped me get an
audition so where do we stand now I was
in LA in January once it was 75 degrees
maybe the movie is making some kind of
statement with the Four Seasons motif
but la has been la no matter what season
I visit not yet Snow's there or
something okay maybe that's his point
but then what's this point I don't care
how famous you are this is some bull
parking there's plenty of room
driver still can't get between the lines
Chinese coffee right even if you saw her
walking up to the shop you still didn't
have time to prepare this order I go to
Starbucks every goddamn day those people
at my local shop are cooking lovely but
even in their speediest they don't do
this book I don't care if she comes in
here every day this is some mind-blowing
coffee preparedness the realization that
she ended up with someone other than
setup is sad sure but it's overshadowed
by the feeling of when Tom Everett's got
been the last decade which is
distracting I wanted to give this movie
props for showing a realistic love story
in which the main characters don't stay
together forever but the fact that both
of these assholes got exactly what they
wanted within five years is so
unbelievable that I'm doubling down on
the signature this ginormous Emma Stone
is famous billboard on the wall of the
jazz club is even more overt and obvious
than the wall of Mary Jane Watson acting
posters in the background as Peter drags
his broken motorcycle in spider-man 2
which is even more interesting given
Emma Stone's own time spent in the
spider-man universe the fact that famous
movie star Mia just happens to be in the
location of Sebastian's new happening
jazz bar on its opening night is a
coincidence wrapped in synchronicity
covered in a thick layer of epilogue and
bull someone is staring at my wife like
this for this long I'm definitely asking
questions and here's where the movie
both treats and wins we get to see that
fairy tale coupling of Mia instead play
out and it feels awesome even though we
know it's not real but then we also get
to see the reality ending where they
both end up apart because sometimes
chasing your dream cost you
relationships
that's deep not only makes the what
could have been montage all the more
heartbreaking strangely enough the bar
they go into in this version of the
story is called Tom efforts cops
for Best Picture la-la land
[Music]
okay fine you either die a hero or you
live long enough to see yourself become
the villain there are no two words in
the English language more harmful than
good job the sound that I get a little
bit nervous is best of all to hear
[Music]